let me go next to our caller from the
nine seven eight nine seven eight who's
this where are you calling from
hello this is right hey ray what's up
not too much how you doing today good
good
first of all I do want to let you know I
love your show I think it's awesome so I
really appreciate what you do I'm not
really a singer but I did write a song
for the president if you'd like to hear
it okay good okay think think of the
Mickey Mouse Club theme okay okay who's
the leader of the states that we are
living in the when al DTR UMP who is the
guy in over said and so clueless the
when al DTR you and Pete Donald Trump
Donald Trump you're ignorant and so
every sponsible who is the kind of get
rid of like who got to get voted out of
office call me Election Day the when al
DTR UMP Wow Wow
speechless I'm without speech awesome
anything my question also is do you
seriously think he has a second chance
you mean do I think Trump is a shot at
getting elected re-elected yes I do
i I think it's a serious shot and I
think we've we've all better make sure
that we've got a functioning election in
November so we can vote him out
absolutely yeah all right thank you very
much appreciated excellent excellent
song and hopefully we don't get a
copyright claim
just from the melody we thought would be
horrible okay that's all the time I have
today appreciate everybody calling in
sorry I couldn't get to everyone but
someday someday we will take calls again